Is it possible to scare off a shark?
The ocean,...
...teeming with life and home to millions of fish,...
...Sea-Monkeys and a fascinating array of sewage and waste.
Yet in these waters dwells one of the most terrifying predators of all: the shark.
Although you're more likely to be hit by lightning than attacked by a shark,...
...lightning isn't six man-eating meters long with hundreds of serrated teeth.
So it's best to know how to protect yourself.
Your first instinct will be to swim away.
And if the distance between you and the shark is great enough, this would be your best bet.
But if it doesn't occur to you to swim away from danger,...
...I would recommend a life spent on dry land.
While swimming near a shark, use smooth strokes because excessive splashing...
...will attract your predator's attention and make you look like food.
Delicious, flailing food.
But if you're too close to escape, some recommend that you swim towards the shark.
This won't likely scare the shark but it will signal aggression.
Sharks respect power.
If that doesn't work, when the predator gets within reach, hit the shark in the nose,...
...taking great care to avoid the massive deadly jaw, of course.
Also, try to claw its eyes and gills, these are the shark's most sensitive areas.
But if all else fails, hands down the number one fail-proof sure-fire way to scare off a shark is...